[Musique]
musique baroque en fond sonore
michel mazans dans son atelier de
graveurs l'ancien élève d'yves carreau à
l'école des beaux-arts d'orléans se
prépare ce matin là au tirage d'une eau
forte qu'elle a elle-même gradé c'est
une des particularités de l'artiste
michel 20 ans réalise personnellement
toutes les techniques et étape de son
art la gravure c'est c'est un combat de
du ce et la recherche de l'ombre de la
lumière donc en fait tous les laits
toutes les étapes de la gravure
c'est cette recherche l'a donc c'est en
faisant ces tirages là que l'on voit
comment peut naître la lumière également
artiste peintre michel vazan se consacre
de plus en plus assidûment à la gravure
la discipline est exigeante mais elle
offre une quasi infinie palette
d'expressions pour l'artiste j'applique
en fait toutes les
toutes les techniques de de la gravure
pour pour pour transmettre en fait ce
que j'ai tout ce que j'ai à dire
engagé dans son art elle expose très
régulièrement
michel vincent l'est tout autant dans
son époque elle anime par exemple des
ateliers de gravure à l'hôpital
psychiatrique d'orléans je fais partie
des gens qui pensent que l'art c'est un
vecteur de communication et je me
bagarre pour que ce soit vraiment un
vecteur de communication sur un plan
humain je trouve que au contraire si ma
porte peut être ouverte c'est très bien
le visiteur n'aura donc même pas à
pousser la porte déjà ouverte de
l'atelier de michel vingt ans durant
tout ce week-end